i firmly believe that the best way to
learn
is to learn from other people's mistakes
not only is it cheap
easy it's also fun so let's dive into it
together
welcome to the 10 billion dollar studio
i'm your host
coffee zilla and welcome back guys you
guys
know that it's the month of the pump so
don't forget
to pump up the stock okay that's first
of all second of all welcome back
my 13 year old bot army guys i don't
know if you realize this but uh we
we were talking all billie jean he told
us tommy look everyone who
watches you is a 13 year old bot so
actually
i took a class photo i went ahead so
someone else made this
i'm pretty sure this is you guys correct
me if i'm wrong like
i see you in the back oh yep that's
probably you watching that right now so
um yeah just just so you know i want to
welcome you guys back
because uh i i don't know if this is on
youtube kids now but
it probably is now we're going to talk
about a lot of different
brand disasters and my hope is you can
learn a thing or two right people always
ask me stephen how did you build such a
distinguished brand
i said yep that hey showing this
so maybe we should start with this big
disposable
underwear now that sounds disgusting
that's because of the brand bic already
has bix known for pins
uh they're known for disposable cheap
stuff and so
the brand was an immediate failure big
disposable underwear
gross i think that's pretty obvious why
that fails right
it might seem like that but then you
have another
giant marketing firm making the same
mistake in a different way
colgate beef lasagna why is this a train
wreck guys let's learn together
well what do you think of when you think
of colgate toothpaste
it's toothpaste who wants the guy who's
making your toothpaste
to make your beef lasagna it's like
finding out that the guy who drives the
garbage truck
is also the creator of san pellegrinio
you know it's like there's just a weird
association there i'm not saying he
doesn't wash his hands afterwards
i'm just saying you don't want that guy
touching your sparkling water
this is a big lesson that brands are
constantly messing
up and if you're going to be a part of
marketing mondays learn from these
mistakes
nobody wants this gross same thing here
again
lifesavers pineapple it just
i don't know hard candy to soda it's too
much this is the one that's closest to
like i'll give it a pass
all these by the way are featured in
matt haig's brand failures i think the
book is called
i highly recommend this book if you want
to learn more about brands
but again though you get the idea the
brand association
ruins what could be a good idea does it
taste good i have no idea
this could be the best meal of my life i
don't know but i pre-judge it because of
the brand
association same thing frito-lay
i guess this is a big i don't know why
all my all the examples i chose
are this like one lesson over and over
again but hey you can learn a thing or
two
frito lay lemonade why would you want to
take it's like you're thinking free to
lay like chips
salty yeah lemonade's a little bit salty
but it's a weird
association you're thinking corn why
this is not good
this is why actually companies like
procter and gamble
are not just one brand they like
multiple brands because especially in
this type of industry if you dominate a
like a certain sector you're sort of
known for that so friday is known for
like chips
they're not known for lemonade so you
need to start up like a whole another
brand that's why they do that
in fact it's what it's the difference
between something called the little
learning lesson here
a branded house versus a house of brands
this isn't even funny this is just like
true
so a branded house is something like
virgin airlines right
virgin airlines it's all the same brand
right product it's this virgin airlines
virgin
mobile virgin it's all under richard
branson's thing so that's a branded
house
everything's under the same brand then
there's a house of brands which is a
different branding style
which procter gamble uses obviously
where they have multiple different
brands that are all
kind of separate and they're supposed to
be separate because they want you to not
associate them together
like procter gamble doesn't benefit you
from knowing that all these brands are
related right
they want each of these brands to have
their own associations uh and that is
once again a house of brands so again
take away
branded house house of brands so that's
the difference and there's different
advantages for both
next mistake guys rj reynolds
made a smokeless cigarette now this is a
bit different this is not
not necessarily that it was too far away
from the original brand
uh it had bigger problems and what's
interesting whoops that's not the one
that's this one what's interesting about
these smokeless cigarettes is it's very
akin to a product that actually ended up
working out right which is the uh the
vape
but unfortunately i guess the time
wasn't ready yet because when rj
reynolds released their
smokeless cigarette there were some big
problems now first of all
this is my favorite there was the taste
issue okay this
made the whole book worth it for me
because when i read this i laughed out
loud
one person who smoked premiere
complained it tasted like [ __ ]
and he was rj reynolds chief executive
okay
so alrighty bit of a problem there but
anybody it doesn't take a market genius
like me to know uh that that's a problem
then there's the damaging rumor that the
smokeless cigarette could be used as a
delivery device for crack cocaine
okay another problem too but then
you had uh the difficulty of using the
product in the first place
inhaling the premiere required
vacuum-powered lungs
lighting it virtually required a blow
torch and if successfully lit with a
match the sulfur reaction produced a
smell
and flavor that left users wretching
okay
okay great book you guys should all read
it to learn more about marketing
now what's the lesson there well it's
kind of several things look you can have
a great idea
but if the product's not there if it
doesn't it's not
actually a good product even if it's
great engineering wise
uh it's genius engineering-wise it's not
gonna work
out so i hope that little hodgepodge
of lessons worked out for you guys hope
you learned something from marketing
mondays
try to do something positive every week
right so that's basically it
branded house house of brands don't
extend your brand too far
have a good product this concluded the
master class on marketing see you next
time
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee